All right. So we just saw Computing the Closure,
which is one way to help us complete the parsing chart--
in fact, it's one of three ways.
Now we're going to see a second
that's sometimes called, Consuming the input
or shifting over the input.
Shifting over the input, consuming the input,
or reading the input is one more way to help complete the parsing chart.
We are going to need all 3 powers, combined,
in order to make a totally complete parsing chart.
But for now, let's worry about the input.
So recall that, very generally,
we could be in a parsing state that looks like this.
This is a rule from our grammar, with a dot added
and this (from) information or starting at information added.
And I've drawn (a) and (b) and (c) and (d) in purple
because we're not sure if they're terminals or nonterminals.
We just saw what to do if (c)--the next thing we're expecting--
is a nonterminal.
We compute the closure by looking at all the rules that start with (c) in the grammar.
But what if (C) is a terminal--
a token, final part of the input?
Well, then we'll just shift over it and consume it.
If we were in this parsing state in chart[i],
that means, after seeing (i) tokens,
this is where we could be.
I'm just going to take my finger and--whoomp--move it to the right one!
So I can just move my finger over,
so that instead of expecting a (c),
I've seen the (c)
if (c) was the ith input token.
This is a prediction we're making: (c) may come in the future.
I go look at what the user actually entered.
If (c) was actually the next token in the input,
the next letter they typed in,
the next word in the program,
then I can shift over it and say great--we have parsed that,
that's just what we were expecting, that totally fits our plan--no problems at all.
So if we were in chart[i],
I'm going to put this new information in chart[i + 1]
because, remember the number here in the chart
corresponds to how many tokens we've seen.
And we're only in this brave new world
after we've seen the (c).
The (c) was one token; previously we'd seen (i) tokens ,
so now we've seen [i + 1] tokens.
This entire approach is called shifting.